machtwechsel in deutschland das was
anderswo alle paar monate passiert ist
hier historisch jetzt ist machtwechsel
in wenigen minuten läuft die neue
regierungsmannschaft auf scholz habe
clinton also die drei männer die ab
jetzt deutschland führen unterschreiben
offiziell ihren deutschland die den
koalitionsvertrag ja und oben rechts
sehen sie schon das livebild große
aufregung hier im politischen berlin wie
gesagt das ist eine historische woche
hier passiert allerhand morgen dann
offiziell die vereidigung und jetzt
tanzen sie hier der hauptstadtpresse
schon mal vor scholz habeck und lindner
und genau dort mittendrin in dem gefühl
ist jetzt unsere kanzler reporterin
angelika hellemann angelika du kannst
uns schon hören und sehen aber wir dich
noch nicht und deswegen sprechen wir
hier im studium mit bildpolitik chef jan
schäfer das ist eine historische woche
die heute noch mal mit einem weiteren
offiziellen schritt ihren anfang nimmt
nämlich unterzeichnung koalitionsvertrag
was erwartest du heute von diesem
auftritt also jetzt wird am ende einmal
nochmal manifestiert was in den letzten
wochen ausgehandelt wurde 177 seiten
koalitionsvertrag dabei bay das sind
zwei seiten mehr als im letzten vertrag
aber gar nicht so viel mehr angela
merkel hat sonst gerne
koalitionsverträge unterschreiben lassen
die er fast 190 seiten stark waren jetzt
also 177 seiten gut wenn wir dann gleich
sehen die drei du hast es auch
angesprochen olaf scholz robert habeck
und christian lindner sind das trio sind
die drei köpfe der kommenden regierung
die frage ist aber sind sie auch alle
gleich mit gleich viel macht
ausgestattet olaf scholz ganz klar als
kanzler die mächtigste person dann
christian lindner als der kassenwart der
künftige finanzminister und dann bin ich
mir gar nicht sicher ob robert habeck
wirklich die nummer drei ist er ist zwar
vizekanzler damit eigentlich die nummer
zwei aber ob er wirklich die nummer drei
ist oder ob das nicht eher karl
lauterbach ist der mann der
wahrscheinlich das schwierigste ressort
erstmal jetzt zu führen bekommt nämlich
gesundheitsminister wird das ist sehr
spannender schauen wir auch nachher
nochmal genau in diese personalie
gestern ja auch wirklich viele dann doch
überraschend wir schauen wir zu angelegt
wenn man sie ist bei uns jetzt
eingeblendet gesehen dieses bild da geht
es gleich los ist wollen wir in den
wenigen minuten auch live zeigen sie ist
für uns dort angelika hellemann unsere
reporterin weshalb wir dort server
ja wir warten jetzt hier alle auf olaf
scholz robert habeck und christian
lendner viele minister sind schon da
also so links hinter mir sitzen sie
schon und warten den größten aufreger
oder auflauf hat tatsächlich auch karl
lauterbach gemacht irgendwann kam hier
wolfgang kubicki rein und hat seinen
großen ja auch kontrahenten in der
korona politik begrüßt und ihm
gratuliert und lauterbach habt eben sehr
sehr viele glückwünsche entgegengenommen
und war so ein bisschen das zentrum des
ganzen trubels
was ist das für eine dunkle bude wurde
der aufbruch gleich verkündet wird
angelika wo laufen wieder auf die drei
lindner habeck und schaut natürlich
dass das hier ist das nennt sich das
futur ii um das ist schon mal von der
bundesregierung genutzt worden
allerdings ist das ziemlich in die hose
gegangen das ist so ein bau der es kann
eben für solche veranstaltungen genutzt
werden hier geht es um zukunft hier gibt
es eine zukunfts ausstellung in berlin
ganz nähe vom kanzleramt ein sehr
futuristischer bau und hier hat die
große koalition tatsächlich mal ihr
energiekonzept vorgestellt dass sie
allerdings dann drei wochen später
wieder einräumen musste weil der co2
preis mit zehn euro einfach viel zu
niedrig angesetzt war und die grünen im
bundesrat gesagt haben wir müssen
zustimmen und da werden wir nicht
zustimmen also hat dieser ort eine
leichte negative geschichtliche färbung
für olaf scholz und co aber das hat sie
nicht gestört foto ri um klingt super
und sie nennen sich ja auch die zukunft
koalition und deswegen fanden sie das
wohl als den richtigen ort sondern wenn
sie jetzt hatte nie glauben auch gerne
sie kommen aber gut nimmt im reichstag
wirtschaft nun 1 verpasst und wir wollen
auch nichts verpassen gucken uns groß
diese bilder kann also drückt sie jetzt
ein die ampelkoalition wir sehen
annalena baerbock sie natürlich den
künftigen kanzler olaf scholz
robert habeck
klar jetzt nehmen die nimmt die ampel
dort erst mal platz offenbar wir
sprechen hier im studio mit bild
politikchef ihren schäfer weiter über
diese historischen momente patricia es
gerade schon gesagt das kommt hier in
deutschland nicht so oft vor dem
regierungswechsel während beispielsweise
die kollegen den österreicher diese
woche auch wieder wechseln aber die
haben das öfter getan in den vergangenen
jahren und monaten was empfindest du im
moment beim blick auf diese bilder die
wir ebenso seltener leben in deutschland
ja ich glaube wir starten oder
deutschland insgesamt startet in ein
neues experiment erstmals seit den 50er
jahren gibt es wirklich wieder drei
parteien die eine bundesregierung bilden
und diese neue ampelkoalition die
startet ja mit multi krisen muss man ja
sagen über allem schwebt corona die
große frage wie bekommen wir diese
pandemie wirklich in den griff und dann
haben wir natürlich auch das thema
inflation was ebenfalls extrem wichtig
ist und ganz ganz viele menschen in
deutschland belastet nicht zu vergessen
die ganze unsichere situation in
osteuropa stichwort flüchtlingskrise
aber auch der konflikt mit russland
ukraine also diese bundesregierung unter
der führung von olaf scholz der sich am
morgen zum bundeskanzler wählen lassen
möchte die steht von anfang an
wahnsinnig im feuer und gerade wenn es
jetzt um die unterzeichnung des
koalitionsvertrages geht dann ist ja
eine entscheidende frage noch offen was
kostet am ende das alles was hier auf
die rampe geschoben werden soll und dazu
finden wir auf den 177 seiten relativ
wenig und vor allem auch die frage der
finanzierung die ist wirklich in vielen
vielen bereichen noch nicht geklärt dass
also vor allem dann auch
herausforderungen für christian lindner
der quasi auf dem geldbeutel sitzt als
künftiger finanzminister der wird da
einiges zu überblicken haben wie es zu
bezahlen gilt die großen pläne die
geschmiedet werden unter anderem 400.000
wohnungen gebaut werden sollen was
erwartest du es heute von dem termin wir
sehen da alle stehen im dunkeln es wird
angestrebt mehr fortschritte erwarten
also dass unter dieser überschrift das
ganze oder hängt das noch aus dem
vorjahr wurde das übernommen
genau das ist auch das was die drei
parteien über den koalitionsvertrag
geschrieben haben also die große klammer
die ist mehr fortschritt wagen das kommt
der spd zugute das kommt den grünen
zugute stichwort klimaschutz aber auch
der fdp die ja viele punkte in den
koalitionsvertrag hineinverhandelt hat
vielleicht schauen wir einmal auch
nochmal auf die minister riege denn das
ist ja auch ganz spannend eine neue
regierung startet ja auch mit vielen
vielen neuen ministerinnen und minister
und wenn wir uns das tableau einmal
anschauen die 15 bundesminister wir
nehmen den bundeskanzler und seinen
kanzleramtsminister einmal raus dann
sind es insgesamt 15 minister die an den
start gehen und nur fünf davon haben
bereits regierungserfahrung
innenminister entern sowohl auf
bundesebene als auch auf landesebene es
heißt 10 also zwei drittel sind völlig
unerfahren was die führung eines hauses
angeht so und da liegt natürlich auch
eine gefahr denn man muss erstmal in
tritt kommen das ist auch ganz normal
dass man natürlich wenn man frischen amt
kommt ein haus erstmal führen muss das
ist nicht ganz glaube ich ungefährlich
da liegt die gefahr einer der der neuen
regierung die vier fdp minister haben
überhaupt keine regierungserfahrung bei
den grünen sind auch drei also das wird
spannend zu sehen sein und heute werden
wir gleich sehen sie sagt vertrag wird
gleich unterschrieben werden mutmaßlich
von den parteichefs und den
generalsekretären hier kommen sie wir
sehen es schon langsam auf die bühne und
ja dann beginnt die zeremonie in wenigen
sekunden dass man strahlendes grün würde
ich sagen annalena baerbock robert
habeck christian lindner olaf scholz
saskia esken und norbert walter borjans
also das ist so ein bisschen harmonie so
wusste natürlich heute und die nächsten
tage werden davon bestimmt sein bevor es
dann richtig an die arbeit geht nach und
nach kommen aber ein bisschen mehr
details raus wie es in den
koalitionsgesprächen zu gehen das können
wir gleich nochmal thematisieren hören
jetzt natürlich rein beim künftigen
kanzler olaf scholz
gute ergebnisse gegeben die dazu
beitragen dass wir in diesem land
fortschritt organisieren kann und
deshalb ist es sehr schön dass wir heute
den koalitionsvertrag für die bildung
dieser regierung unterzeichnen können
wenn die gute zusammenarbeit die während
der zeit der bildung der regierung schon
geklappt hat dann auch weiter klappt
dann wird das eine sehr sehr gute zeit
für die aufgaben die vor uns liegen in
den beginnenden 20er jahren und wir
vergessen dabei nicht während wir mit
dem aufdruck beginnen haben wir noch
eine schwere aufgabe zu bewältigen
nämlich die korona krise zu bekämpfen
und das wird unsere ganze kraft und
energie fordern
guten morgen
bis jetzt haben wir für unsere parteien
und als parteien miteinander verhandelt
ab heute sind wir dann eine regierung
sicherlich in den unterschieden immer
wieder erkennbar aber eben eine
regierung für die menschen in
deutschland die zunächst erst einmal die
große krise unserer gegenwart die korona
von dem die bewältigen muss die krise
diese vielen menschen jetzt über so
lange zeit so viel zugemutet hat darüber
hinaus allerdings gibt es die großen
strukturellen veränderungen die im
zentrum der regierungsarbeit stehen
werden und das ist sicherlich vor allem
die größte industrie nation europas die
viertgrößte volkswirtschaft der welt auf
eine klimaneutrale auf einen
klimaneutralen kurs zu bringen
klimaneutralität und wohlstand in diesem
land zusammen zu denken und zusammen zu
bringen und diese aufgabe werden wir uns
gemeinsam stellen
ja guten morgen meine damen und herren
wir haben jetzt lange und viel
miteinander gesprochen
wir haben lange und intensiv mit unseren
parteien gesprochen und wir haben auch
mit der öffentlichkeit intensiv in den
letzten tagen und wochen gesprochen
jetzt beginnt die zeit der tat wir haben
gesagt wir wollen mehr fortschritt wagen
ab dieser woche wollen wir am
fortschritt arbeiten wir geben uns
keiner illusion hin das sind große
herausforderungen vor denen wir stehen
aber
auch wenn die aufgaben die
herausforderungen groß sind unsere
ambition und
unsere bereitschaft zum engagement die
sind es eben auch
sehr guten morgen auch von meiner seite
unsere parteien haben uns in den letzten
drei tagen mit sehr großer mehrheit
zustimmung zu diesem koalitionsvertrag
ein starkes mandat verlieren jetzt
dieses bündnis einzugehen gemeinsam jahr
mehr fortschritt zu wagen
technologischen fortschritt digitalen
fortschritt ökologischen fortschritt
daraus eben auch sozialen fortschritt zu
machen für den zusammenhalt dieser
gesellschaft zu sorgen dafür auch dafür
finde ich ist dieses bündnis ganz
besonders geeignet und jetzt machen wir
uns gemeinsam an die arbeit und freuen
uns sehr darauf
schönen guten morgen
mit diesem koalitionsvertrag kommen wir
jetzt auf der höhe der wirklichkeit auf
der höhe der gesellschaftlichen realität
an und es gilt jetzt diesen
koalitionsvertrag mit weitblick mit
pragmatismus und vor allen dingen auch
mit viel leidenschaft mit leben zu
füllen und zwar nicht für uns als
regierung nicht für uns als parteien
sondern für die menschen in diesem land
und zwar die menschen in ihrer vielfalt
ob alt ob jung ob hier geboren ob
zugezogen dieser fortschritt den wir in
den koalitionsvertrag verankert haben
spiegelt die vielfalt in unserem land
wieder und diese vielfalt ist der light
stab für die nächsten jahre unserer
gemeinsamen zusammenarbeit
ja guten morgen ich bin vor zwei jahren
angetreten um
mitzuhelfen dass wir bremsen lösen und
dass wir dem wandel eine richtung geben
und jeder kann sich vorstellen dass wenn
zwei jahre später wir zusammenstehen und
diesen vertrag unterschreiben wollen wie
sich das anfühlt ich kann nur sagen wir
haben gemeinsam eine menge erreicht und
allen anderen hier auf der bühne kann
ich jetzt sagen macht was draus für die
zukunft unseres landes
[Applaus]
sowohl bei
also jetzt dieser historische moment an
denen man sich irgendwann im guten oder
im schlechten erinnern wird olaf scholz
robert habeck setzten ihre
unterschriften unter den
koalitionsvertrag einer geht dann zurück
in die spd-zentrale einer in die grünen
zentrale einer die fdp-zentrale und
irgendwann vielleicht ins haus der
geschichte damit
jetzt ebenfalls seine unterschrift unter
ein hammer noch und dann ist deutschland
am plaza spa es muss natürlich auch nur
die sind immer dabei die beiden
parteivorsitzenden der spd
richtig die sind immer dabei dazu
christian lindner in gewisser weise
einfacher ist bisher alles in einer
person parteichef fraktionschef und
künftig auch finanzminister wird dann
das amt des fraktionschefs abgeben aber
ganz klar natürlich olaf scholz als
künftiger kanzler hat noch zwei
parteivorsitzende saskia esken und
norbert walter borjans und norbert
walter borjans am ende auf und hat
gesagt macht etwas draus das kann man
als appell verstehen an diejenigen die
jetzt die regierung führen denn norbert
walter borjans scheidet ja nächste woche
als spd-chef aus und wird dann ersetzt
durch lars klingbeil also jetzt norbert
walter borjans der auch noch sein
autogramm darunter setzt unter den
koalitionsvertrag dass also der formale
akt das macht man jetzt weil die
parteitage eben ja zwischendurch noch
entscheiden mussten über den
koalitionsvertrag auch dass er in diesem
fall eine formale zustimmung noch gegen
überall sauber durch bei der fdp ein
bisschen mehr grummeln dann und ein
bisschen mehr nein- stimmen als bei
anderen aber letztlich wie gesagt nur
ein formaler akt das hat man jetzt
geschafft aber die ganze zeremonie ist
natürlich irgendwie wirkt getragen aber
auch ein bisschen gedrückt also der
dunkle raum und da ist so fehlt
natürlich so ein bisschen der esprit den
man eigentlich ausstrahlen wenn mit
diesem koalitionsvertrag jetzt sehen wir
die fraktionsvorsitzenden der grünen die
noch kommen die auch den
koalitionsvertrag mit ausgehandelt habe
und ich unterschreiben werden und dann
müssten eigentlich am schluss auch noch
die generalsekretäre und bei den grünen
der bundesgeschäftsführer kommen also
wie eine geburtstagskarte auf der die
ganze familie nummer unterschreibt jetzt
eben auch katrin göring eckardt
unverkennbar auch von oben also auf
einen stift bei der im irak hätten einen
stift gesucht in leipzig laden an die
bereitliegenden kugelschreiber gewand
nicht manche sind ja mit dem eigenen
schiff gekommen aber du hast dich
inszenierung angesprochen ja das stimmt
ich habe ja auch gerade gesagt und wie
dunkle bude das ist jetzt nicht ganz so
wie vielleicht vielleicht schon andere
auftritt der ampel auch bisher also wenn
man jetzt ganz fies wäre könnte man
sagen da tragen sich alle irgendwie ins
kondolenzbuch eins ist ganz still im
raum also es fehlt eigentlich der
aufbruch der ausgestrahlt werden soll
kommt zumindest bei dieser veranstaltung
jetzt gar nicht zur geltung und wir
sehen natürlich ein schwer genervten
toni hofreiter der ja bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen noch eine
maßgebliche führende rolle gespielt hat
aber dann komplett ausgebootet wurden
jetzt kommt lasst klingen bei der spd
generalsekretär und mutmaßlich künftige
spd chef
er hat ja auch dafür gesorgt maßgeblich
dass der wahlkampf der spd so
erfolgreich gelaufen ist und kann sich
wenn es darum geht wer bekommt ein
großes stück von der torte von der
sieger tore warf scholz sicherlich ein
großes stück abschneiden lass es einmal
darüber sprechen wie ehrlich das jetzt
ist denn ich habe ja schon gesagt da
kommen jetzt immer mehr zwischentöne wie
das wirklich gelaufen ist in den
koalitionsverhandlungen in den
sondierungsgesprächen hatte anfangs
annalena baerbock schon mal gesagt na ja
es gab schon auch die momente wo wir
ziemlich genervt voneinander waren und
jetzt sagt robert habeck auch dass da
türen geknallt wurden dass man sich an
gebrüllt hat und so weiter das heißt
ganz so harmonie war dass die letzten
wochen nicht wir erinnern uns an dieses
elfi was ja dokumentieren sollte wir
machen diesmal alles anders aber da ist
natürlich wenn menschen zum teil dann 18
stunden aufeinanderhocken miteinander
verhandeln und zwar aus ganz
unterschiedlichen richtungen kommen die
einen von den grünen die anderen von der
fdp sehr sehr weit auseinander und die
sitzen zusammen 18 stunden lang und
müssen jetzt ein gemeinsames papier auf
den weg bringen das natürlich klar dass
es da reibungspunkte gibt reibereien und
das da ordentlich auch mal auf den tisch
gehauen wird deswegen zu glauben dass
wir alles harmonisch hätten wir auch im
vorfeld nicht und es ist gut dass da
jetzt nach und nach heraus dringt dass
es menschen sind die da verhandelt haben
und dass es ordentlich gekracht hat wer
spannend wo das ding jetzt hingeht was
passiert mit dem unterschriebenen
koalitionsvertrag eigentlich der wird
zumindest online auch einzusehen sein
also alle parteien veröffentlichen
veröffentlichen denen natürlich auch es
gibt jetzt hier verhaltenen applaus die
behörden das aber auch trotzdem ein
historischer moment sehen wir sie 177
seiten stark aller haben unterschrieben
die ampel steht jetzt wirklich und es
gibt halt kein publikum soviel zum
verhaltenen applaus das sind halt
fotografen ein paar journalisten
zugelassen außerdem eben dann die
künftigen minister und
fraktionsvorsitzenden usw cem özdemir
zum beispiel gerade gesehen also claudia
roth sind auch ganz vorne zwar hält man
die frage bei den 177 seiten weil du
bist gerade noch mal gesagt dass auch
patricia was muss eigentlich alles in so
einem koalitionsvertrag stehen musste
eigentlich bis ins letzte komma
ausformuliert sein oder geht es eher um
die großen grundzüge beispielsweise
unter gerhard schröder in der regierung
da waren koalitionsvertrag nicht mal
hundert seiten stark und man hat aber
festgestellt es ist doch besser dinge
wirklich auf den punkt zu formulieren um
dann koalitionskrach während einer
regierung auch zu verhindern um sagen zu
können wir haben es doch eigentlich ganz
genau festgelegt und nichtsdestotrotz
hat trotzdem vor beginn den ersten krach
schon geben über die frage besteuert man
in dieser künftig stärker und belastet
man autofahrer oder wird es keine
mehrbelastung geben